for the second time in just over a year
Chileans are being presented with a text
for a new constitution left-wing
president Gabriel bich tried to mask his
disappointment with the right leaning
draft whatever the Chilean people's
final word can say that our mechanisms
and form of interacting politically
continue to be essentially institutional
and
Democratic in September last year
Chileans rejected a draft Charter
written primarily by left-wing delegates
it guaranteed social rights gender
parity abortion Environmental Protection
and much more but for the majority it
went too far this time the pendulum has
swung to the extreme political right
which controlled the process with veto
power this new constitution eliminates
political debate four years ago millions
of Chileans took to the streets to
demand a new constitution to replace
their current dictatorship era Charter
then as now better public health
education and pensions were at the top
of their demands yet the new convention
couldn't resolve these fundamental
issues the issue is that we we have been
trying to put this kind of decision at
the Constitutional level and it
shouldn't be probably at the
Constitutional level many are frustrated
and even embarrassed in 6 weeks Chileans
will again vote in a referendum that
according to polls is likely to reject
this latest attempt to give Chile a
constitution that can unite the country
and if that is the case there won't be
another chance for a very very long time
to come Lucia Newman Al jazer
Santiago make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer